Richard Dawkins is no friend to
conservatives the atheist author spent
much of his life to ride in Judaism
Christianity he once said that an
atheist is called just somebody who
feels about Yahweh the way any decent
Christian feels about Thor or Baal or
the Golden Calf Dawkins says that even
moderate religious people quote make the
world safe for extremists he's fired the
left on politics he's from or ssin a
supporter of the Labour Party and
Liberal Democratic Party in Britain but
he is also smart enough to recognize
that radical Islam is a greater threat
to human life than Christianity or
Judaism Dawkins explains quote I have
criticized the appalling misogyny and
homophobia of Islam I have criticized
the murdering of apostates for no crime
other than their disbelief Muslims
themselves are the prime victims of the
oppressive cruelties of Islamism such
language of course makes him a pariah
among leftist this week Dawkins was
scheduled to speak at an event with KPFA
in Brooklyn California all went
swimmingly until leftist realized
Dawkins had said some untoward things
about Islam then they canceled the
speech citing his quote/unquote abusive
speech they explained quote we had
booked this event based entirely on his
excellent new book on science when we
didn't know he had offended and hurt in
his tweets and other comments on his on
so many people KPFA does not endorse
hurtful speech this is no shock the same
left that barred Dawkins from his
Berkley event shared this week while
Palestinian Arabs riot over metal
detectors at the Temple Mount those
leftists proclaimed but the true
obstacle to peace in the Middle East
isn't Palestinian air violence isn't
Palestinians who stabbed his railey
Druze police officers on the stem on the
Temple Mount or Palestinians who invade
homes and slaughter old men and women or
the Palestinians and government who
cheer honor and financially support such
behavior nope the problem is the Jews
the same elected blames metal detectors
for murderous assaults and Richard
Dawkins for offending Islam makes
excuses for radical Muslim and women's
March organizer Linda Sarsour who is
called for apostate Muslims to have
their genitals removed who says the
Zionists cannot be feminists and who
stands up for terrorists and terrorist
orders so why do the let's seek to
support radical Islam so ardently well
because the left believes it's a
quickest way to destroy Western
civilization is no longer class warfare
the multi cultural warfare simply allied
with groups that hate the prevailing
system and work with them to take it
down then the left will build on the
ashes of the old system in this view
Dawkins is an opponent how can left
recruit Muslims to fight the same system
if Dawkins is to be alienating them they
support the Palestinian terror regime
how can that colonialist output without
Israel be defeated without a little
blood a flawed star sewer she's an
allies that means she must be backed
alliance with nefarious forces cause
your own morality into question KPFA has
a lot more to answer for than Dawkins
but the left will never have to answer
such questions so long as they focus in
on their common enemy a supposedly
conservative establishment that must be
fought with any tool at their disposal
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show okay so we have a lot to talk about
in Trump Ville today so president Trump
is obviously attacking the Attorney
General Sessions Sessions is saying that
he is not going to go without being
pushed out the door we'll talk about
what that means plus the Senate
Republicans are finally going to vote on
some form of care we don't know exactly
what that is yet but it appears to vote
to proceed on some form of Obamacare
change is going to happen so we'll talk
about that as well Democrats in
confusion plus Trump talks to a bunch of
children at the Boy Scouts and it goes
weird we'll talk about all those things
before we do that first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over a legacy
box so this is a business that I think
is a must use for anybody who wants to
preserve their memories so I'm very big
into preserving memories family memories
very into assuring that our family
photos stay ensuring that our ensuring
that our family photos are preserved and
that are in that our cakes are preserved
and our videos are preserved so we can
watch them later well that's exactly
what legacy box does and we're not just
talking about digital stuff we're
talking about the stuff that you have in
your garage right now we are talking
about all those old stacks and boxes of
photos and film reels you take them and
put them in a box you send it to legacy
box legacy box gives you labels that you
put on each item so you know where they
are and the process and then legacy box
takes all that stuff and they weave it
into one DVD or a set of DVDs or onto a
thumb drive and they send it back to you
so it's ready to use and ready to play
and so there's a fire in your house or a
flood you don't have to worry about all
the memories that are going to be
destroyed that's exactly what legacy box
is for over a quarter million families
have used them terrific people go to
legacy voxcom slash men you get a 40%
discount on your order that the legacy
box.com slash been and again get that
40% discount legacy box comm slash but
you know as somebody who has
grandparents who are getting up there it
would be tragic if their memories were
lost
all time too tragic if you don't
preserve the memories of your
grandparents your parents your own
family that's what legacy box is for
legacy box calm slash spend 40% off
right now and use that flash gun Plus
that lets them know that we tell you
okay so President Trump is very very
very angry at Attorney General Jeff
Sessions he has decided to make Jeff
Sessions the focus of designer why well
not because Jeff Sessions is doing a
terrible job in fact by most accounts
he's doing a pretty good job
particularly on immigration if there's
anything that can be said about Jeff
Sessions that he's too ardent with
regard to the civil forfeiture the
attempt to grab property after an arrest
but before a conviction right there he's
wrong but everything else Jeff Sessions
has been doing a pretty good job as
Attorney General
I haven't seen any problems with Jeff
Sessions but Trump sees one big problem
and that is determining General Sessions
obviously has not done enough to protect
Donald Trump Trump has gotten to the
point where he is starting to see
everything in terms of how it affects
him personally not his presidency him
personally and so this morning him
leashed a series of nasty tweets about
Jeff Sessions so he tweeted quote
Ukrainian efforts to sabotage Trump
campaign quietly working to boost
Clinton so where is the investigation AG
and then he said Attorney General Jeff
Sessions has taken a very weak position
on Hillary Clinton crimes where our
emails in DNC server and Intel leakers
then he said problem is the acting head
of the FBI and the person in charge of
the Hillary investigation Andrew McCabe
got seven hundred thousand dollars from
Hillary for wife so now he's attacking
the Deputy Attorney General oh we're
sorry the acting ahead of the FBI so
just to put this all in perspective in
the first six months of the Trump
administration inspired Mike Flynn
supposedly for lying to vice president
pence that's not really why that
happened he's fired the FBI director
James Comey and said openly and it's
because of Comey handling of the Russian
stuff he is now threatening Attorney
General Sessions he has threatened his
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
and that New York Times interview last
week he has attacked the acting head of
the FBI and his attack the special
counsel so what do all these people have
in common they're all involved in the in
the Russia investigation all people who
he's tapped or has or has said that he
wants to cap he is now put to the side
he did they're all involved in the
Russian investigation which says one of
two things either that Trump is a
narcissist when it comes to this Russia
thing he was really bothered by it it
bothers him in a significant way and he
just wants to end it by getting rid of
anyone who has failed to shut it down or
who continues to pursue it or he has
nothing to hide right those are really
the only two choices there is no choice
three so either this is pathological
narcissism or this is krump has
something to hide now I tend to believe
it's pathological narcissism and again
I've said before my entire theory here
is the Trump really hasn't done anything
wrong
and he's ticked that everybody isn't
just stopping this nonsense already and
so he wants to fire everyone but let's
be straight about Jeff Sessions here
okay Jeff Sessions is not responsible
for this Jeff Sessions only recused
himself because in his own testimony he
said that he never had a meeting with
Russians it turned out he had a meeting
with Ambassador surrogate kis lyac so he
recused himself that happened long after
he was nominated and approved for the
position the actual recusal and there's
no way for him know that this stuff was
really going to come up it doesn't make
a lot of sense plus Jeff Sessions is the
lifeline he is the the the hardwiring
into the nationalist populist movement
that Trump likes to talk so much about
and from which he draws to support
sessions is the font head for the
anti-immigration movement that Trump
supposedly represents so this doesn't
make a whole hell of a lot of sense oh
there are a few things that I want to
say about all this first of all
scaramouche me the Anthony's care moved
to the new chief staff he's not to staff
yet but he may well be the head of
communications for Donald Trump he was
on to Hewitt's show this morning and he
basically said yes Trump wants Jeff
Sessions to resign here's what the muj
had to say ah the president's been
tweeting this morning Trey awareness why
not Evan why not just fire jeff Sessions
well listen I mean you know I think the
president has a certain style certain
skill set
he's obviously frustrated I said
yesterday I think the Sarah Marie maybe
the two of them to get together my guess
is the president but doesn't want to do
that and so I think it's going to I
think him and Jeff or sorry Attorney
General Sessions need to work this thing
out they can all hear that does it want
some gun I have enormous amount of
respect for the Attorney General but I
do know the president pretty well and
there's this level of tension in the
relationship that that's that's public
you're probably right but I don't want
to speak for the President on that
because use a cabinet official I sort of
think that has to be between the
president United States and the cabinet
official so scared Lucci says I don't
know what is going to do by Yackey
shorter he sort of should go so there
are a bunch of questions your number one
why Trump doesn't just fire him there is
a rumor today the Trump was doing this
just because this is what trunk does
meaning that he got rid of Comey most
humiliating way possible he fired
tamales on the west coast speaking to a
bunch of FBI fidex
and and then he saw it on TV - now he's
doing the same thing to Jeff Sessions
again the problem here is that Sessions
himself is pretty popular with the right
wing of the Republican Party especially
because of immigration issues and that
reputation is well-deserved so let's
talk about some of the the problems here
number one President tough climate
ballsy over here he is he's going to
fire sessions he should just fire
session so he made his entire career I'm
going to fire people but instead he's
giving sessions the runaround why
because you want sessions to resign he
wants sessions to do it on his own he
doesn't want to fire sessions because
for some reason from think that if you
openly pressure sessions to quit and
then sessions quit the blowback will
come back to trump that somehow sessions
will be blamed for that I don't know
where he's getting that idea but it's
foolish if sessions quits at this point
no one's going to blame him everybody's
going to blame Trump second point this
is a very dangerous it's a very
dangerous president that's being set by
the Trump by by the current White House
and that is if you're not obsequious
enough to President Trump or if you
don't spend your entire career capital
trying to support President Trump in
every single way then you should throw
you out scatter Lucci said something
else in this Hewitt interview he said
Eric Holder acted as a goalie for
President Obama we need somebody who's
going to act as a goalie for President
Trump that's really not the job of the
Attorney General and just because Eric
Holder's did the wrong thing doesn't
mean that Jeff Sessions should either
Sarah Moochie of all people shouldn't be
talking about this considering be
tweeted just a few months ago that he
was in favor of sessions we're accusing
himself but this is kind of nasty tenor
that's come to the Trump White House
which is if you don't scrape and bow
before Trump obsequious ly enough then
he's going to behead you Joffrey style
really really unpleasant right Sean
Spicer wasn't just out that he was
humiliated Trump refused to take him on
that tour of the Vatican even though
Spicer's a lifelong Catholic very ardent
Catholic and wanted to meet the Pope and
Trump left him behind
yesterday Trump was speaking to the Boy
Scouts he brought virtually all of the
Eagle Scouts and his administration to
this event he left Jeff Sessions at home
and the third point here Trump right now
is supposed to be pushing it Healthcare
will talk about front pushing health
care in just a minute immediately after
he tweeted all this stuff about Jeff
Sessions he fired off a bunch of Tweety
tweeted big day for health care after
seven years of talking we will soon see
whether or not Republicans are willing
to step up to
place Obamacare's torturing the american
people etc et-cetera well that should be
the entire message room today should it
not and that way when the senate votes
as it did i believe to proceed on a
motion to proceed on some form of trump
care bill then hank when victory you can
say look it was me right instead all the
headlines they're going to be about jeff
sessions and that is Trump's own fault
that is Trump's own fault and there's no
way to escape that ok another point here
and this is the big one I think and the
reason that you're seeing a split in
among conservatives about Trump doing
this stuff like there wasn't a big split
among conservatives about Trump firing
coming yeah I said the Trump shirt of
fired call me I was fine with Trump
firing coming I just thought that his
excuse for doing so it was stupid and
problematic but firing Comey itself I
didn't see any problem with firing
session a lot of people including
Breitbart which is been a cheerleader
for Trump all the way through britt hume
who really likes trump unboxit all all
the people on the right are now saying
sessions is a bridge too far there's a
reason for this and the reason for that
is the Jeff Sessions is a deeply
conservative down when it comes to
immigration so story time a few years
back I'm about three years ago there was
a horowitz Freedom Center event and this
Horowitz Freedom Center event
essentially included a dinner and after
the dinner after the dinner there was a
drinking a late-night drinking session
it was basically a bunch of people
hanging around by the end of the night
the only people who are hanging around
or me and Jeff Sessions and and a bunch
of sorry me Jeff Sessions Stephen Miller
and and Ann Coulter that was the entire
drinking session as four of us and we
were sitting around the only topic that
was discussed the entire evening was
immigration
and it was very clear that this was the
working group for what would become the
Trump administration in fact later
you've been in my former boss over
Breitbart would apparently commissioned
a white paper in 2015 from Coulter and
Miller and Noah at that time was an aide
to session and sessions for a for an
immigration policy and so a lot of the
idea is that that made Trump President a
lot of the immigration I did the made
current President came directly from
Jeff Sessions in fact Jeff Sessions said
to me at the time at the center he said
that he was looking for a candidate to
support in the Republican race who had
embraced his immigration program Trump
was that man in fact sessions is one of
the first people on board with this
whole thing sessions is one of the first
people to endorse Trump right much
earlier than anybody else
now Trump is turning around crapping all
over him because he doesn't like what
he's doing on Russia what's being had
what's happening right now is basically
everybody who wants policy inside the
Trump administration is being sidelined
in favor of people who show personal
loyalty to Trump so spice our foreign
policy out rights once policy sidelines
and influence policy sidelines sessions
once policy sidelined all the people who
actually want conservative policy
currently are being sidelined in favor
of Jared navona personal loyalty to
Trump scaramouche II personal loyalty to
Trump Geary code and personal loyalty to
Trump a lot of people who are really
Democrats who have a lot of personal
loyalty to Trump and Trump is
surrounding himself with those people
getting rid of sessions would be a
disaster area because that basically
mean the only person he's going to
appoint this attorney general is
somebody who's in a vow to fire to him
who's going to vow to fire the special
counsel if the special counsel is fired
you're going to see all hell break loose
in Washington DC it doesn't mean
impeachment at least not right now it
does mean that you're going to see a lot
of kickback from Senate Republicans and
Trump's agenda completely stalls final
points on the sessions thing and then I
want to talk about some other topics a
president Trump in the industry storm
about sessions once again he uses
Hillary Clinton as his excuse I grow
tired and weary of this routine okay
Hillary Clinton is vanquished by
President Trump Thank You president
Trump thank you for that we don't have
Hillary Clinton as our president and for
that I am eternally grateful now she's
gone stop it enough okay she's not
important anymore okay the fact is that
you're not angry with Jeff Sessions
because of Hillary Clinton just like you
weren't angry FBI director Comey over
Hillary Clinton this is all just red
meat for rubes okay people who believe
that that President Trump is actually
angry too Jeff Sessions over Hillary
Clinton that's nonsense okay it was
President Trump who instructed Jeff
Sessions and everybody who's
investigating to leave the Clinton
family alone back in December this is
public okay there wasn't there was no
secret about this so this notion that he
just throws out Hillary Clinton's name
and we're all supposed to just bow
before his wishes it's really silly okay
Hillary has nothing to do with this
he'll already may well deserve to be
prosecuted I'd be fine with prosecuting
Hillary Clinton oh that would be very
difficult now that Trump is basically
tainted the entire jury pool of the
United States but you know I'm fine with
that but to pretend that that's what the
sessions thing is about that is just an
excuse everybody knows the real thing
that's happening here is he kicked
that sessions will act as he shield on
Russia and so he's acting out against
sessions this is a pretty stark litmus
test for a lot of conservatives are you
going to stand with the president
getting rid of an actual conservative on
his key issue immigration inside his
cabinet for no reason reason other than
personal peek there is another reason
it's just see that okay are you gonna
stand with that because come from from
from Trump or are you going to say mr.
president you want to get the policy
done we do too you want to see this
Russia investigation thing comes to a
good close
we do too it can't fire the Attorney
General who helps get you there and who
has been me stalwart on the key issue in
your campaign again is not me saying
this alone this is even his greatest
allies like Breitbart are saying this
sort of thing so you know this is not
anything new but again I think that it
goes to a character problem that Trump
has and that is that he's so ensconced
in his own narcissism he is he's so
pathologically narcissistic that he's
willing to fire even the people who are
his friends the only friends he has left
their family at this point that's really
not a good way to run the operation
sessions for his set for his own sake he
says I'm not leaving he says if Trump
wants to fire me he's going to have to
fire me which by the way is a good
conservative move gave Trump wants to
own this let Trump own it don't let him
off the hook
make fire jeff Sessions we need Jeff
Sessions in place not for civil asset
forfeiture but we need Jeff Sessions in
place for immigration we need Jeff
Sessions in place for for for
application of the law we need him in
place his strength in the police there
are a thousand reasons the Jeff Sessions
@ag is a good thing for the conservative
movement but you know him him being
forced out by Trump is just a disaster
okay so I want to talk about Trump at
the Boy Scouts is actually more
hilarious than it was upsetting but what
is there a upset about this I want to
talk about why I was laughing at it but
first or if they thank you to our
sponsors over at math Weldon so Matt
Weldon is better than whatever you are
wearing right now
they make undergarments they make
underwear socks shirts undershirts
hoodie sweatpants all become for wear
that you actually spend most of your
life in when you're not at the office
and even under the office considering
underwear and talk that's what Mac
Weldon puts you in and it is just
high-quality stuff they have a line of
silver underwear and shirts that are
naturally antimicrobial
meaning they eliminate odor and they
want you to be comfortable so if you
don't like your first pair you can keep
it and we'll still refund you no
question at they look
they perform well too one of my pet
peeves about underwear is that underwear
wears out incredibly quickly and
depending on how many times you put it
through the wash I've had Mac welds and
underwear pairs maxwell's and underwear
for months now and they are exactly the
same as when I bought them no they are
just fantastic Mac Weldon check it out
Mac Weldon calm and get 20% off your
order using promo code Shapiro
that's sha pee IRL Mac Weldon is spelled
ma CK wel do n Mac Weldon com get 20%
off using that promo code Shapiro again
the best stuff the best underwear the
best socks shirts undershirts hoodie
sweatpants in the business go ahead and
check them out and use promo code
Shapiro so that they know that we sent
you all right so when Trump isn't busy
trying to fire his Attorney General for
no apparent reason
the Trump is speaking with the Boy
Scouts but I want to get to that in just
a second first I want discuss what's
happening on the floor of the Senate so
the latest on the floor of the Senate is
the Senate is going to vote on a motion
to proceed on something we don't know
what that something is we don't know
what exactly it's supposed to be we do
know that the that the that there's good
shot that 51 senators are going to are
going to vote in favor of some sort of
saying right they're going to vote in
favor of some sort of things so there's
there some things that's happened one 51
senators have to vote on a motion to
proceed that means they will take up the
House version of Obamacare replacement
and then we actually have to pass a bill
so the key vote is this one because once
you get past that then it's just a
question of hashing out the details now
it could still fall apart it could be
the detail suck we don't know the answer
to that but Trump is bringing on the
pressure and this is what Trump is doing
something good this is what Trump should
be focused on so yesterday Trump was out
there something on Obama care and he
said Obamacare is death
okay third up here he is president Trump
using the power of his presidential
bully pulpit against the backdrop of the
Blue Room and the faces of what the
White House calls the victims of
Obamacare it was a big fat ugly lie with
doom and gloom declarations the
president railed against the law of the
land not surprisingly swiping at
Democrats they run out they say death
death death well Obamacare is death
okay so that's fair enough from
President Trump and he was pushing very
hard he's complimenting Senator McCain
who he's not always been more with
Senator McCain just showed up on the
Senate floor and gave a speech that is
being hailed by a lot of people with
regard to President Trump and with
regard to the Republican handling of
Obamacare in the house or in the Senate
and I'm sure we'll have more clips of
that tomorrow for you because sort of
big moment Trump also is attempting to
push senators says the senators who
don't vote for whatever this is no no
this is yet but who don't vote for this
on Obamacare is a push they want to
forget about the countless Americans
they've heard and the many that they are
continuing to hurt every day by refusing
to help us replace Obamacare for the
last seven years Republicans have been
united in standing up for Obama cares
victims remember repeal and replace
repeal and replace they kept saying it
over and over again every Republican
running for office promised immediate
relief from this disastrous law we as a
party must fulfill that solemn promise
to the voters of this country to repeal
and replace what they've been saying for
the last seven years
but so far Senate Republicans have not
done their job in ending the Obamacare
nightmare okay so you know Trump putting
putting the the pressure on his on his
fellow Republicans in the Senate McCain
basically called for bipartisanship and
we will see if he votes in favor of the
the motion to proceed so we'll give you
all the updates on that as it comes in
Trump is doing the right thing and
putting pressure on the Senate to take
this up big question is going to be
what's in that bill what's in that bill
it is not sufficient just to pass any
bill and I know that you're going to
hear a lot from from Republican
partisans today saying well they have to
vote for something okay well it depends
on what the something is do you even
want to own Obamacare and put the GOP
stamp of approval on it right now what
they're talking about is something I'm
calling skinny repeal okay which is
again just their branding effort is
spectacular skinnier repeal would
apparently begin getting rid of the
individual mandate I don't think it gets
I don't think it reinforces the the new
version of the mandate but getting rid
of the individual mandate getting rid of
some of the taxes getting rid of the
employer may
it gets rid of the funding mechanism for
Obamacare in other words that would
exacerbate steps spiral and then the
Republicans would have to come up with
some new legislation to deal with the
fallout from that which presumably they
would do in another bill after they pass
this one so that's not a terrible
strategy as far as it goes but we'll
talk more about that plus Trump spoke at
the Boy Scouts it was pretty hilarious
we'll talk about that in just a second
but for that I'm gonna have to go over
to daily wire comm and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe to daily
wire yes you you the person listening
right now we're a video show you can
watch the show see the clips see my
faces of amusement and amazement about
politics and not only that yet the
website at Bree gets be part of the
mailbag we will only answer your
questions it's one part of mailbag you
can be part of Andrew Cravens podcast as
well and Michael knows god help us as a
show coming out as well that you can be
a part of that comes out next week all
of that when you get your subscription
over at daily wire it's going the annual
subscription which is what I recommend
you also get a magnificent unbelievable
tumbler it is so precious I had to leave
it in my studio at home I could not
bring it with me because it is too
precious to carry with me
it must be left in a guarded vault where
we have three security guards
so the Joker doesn't steal it it says
left this here is hot or cold you get
that for free when you become an annual
subscriber for just $99 a year to go
over and check that on over at daily
we're calm your listen later go to
iTunes or SoundCloud subscribe leave the
sérgio we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so yesterday president from spoke
at the at the boys couch and he's
getting all sorts of flack from the left
for speaking at the Boy Scouts because
Trump went there and it was pretty
ridiculous he treated the Boy Scouts
like it was a typical political rally
Chuck Todd was particularly sad Chuck
Todd tweeted out how dare President
Trump
Jesus it please presidents don't put the
Boy Scouts in this situation keep
politics out of the Jamboree
what a mess totally unfair to these kids
okay so before I begin with the with the
critique of Trump let me just say this
I have grounds to stand on in critiquing
Trump with regard to the sack or
dissemination of the Boy Scouts that's
because I haven't said that the Boy
Scouts should be mandatorily forced to
open to girls
okay the entire left has said that the
Boy Scouts should allow transgender boys
meaning girls who believe they are boys
into the Boy Scouts and the entire left
has suggested that the Boy Scouts should
be removed of their IRS 501c3 status if
they do not allow gays Scout masters and
gay scouts as you need people talk about
their sexuality in the Boy Scouts now so
the less doesn't have any ground when
they talk about the sacrosanct Boy
Scouts we must protect them okay I'm not
going to take that crap for a bunch of
people who have been trying to destroy
the Boy Scouts for nigh on two decades
can that's stuff I'm going to wash
anyway so Trump does speak in front of
the Boy Scouts and it is pretty wild so
first of all as the Boy Scouts were
chanting that they love Trump and people
in the media can't understand this may
be the reason for that is a lot of the
people who are in the Boy Scouts have
evangelical parents come from
conservative areas here's some tape of
the Boy Scouts chanting that they like
Trump
[Applause]
by the way just a question did President
Obama ever come to a Jamboree
okay so Trump being Trump doing his
rally routine I am going out there and
saying and politicizing we can't just
accept the phrase yes to riff on
President Obama at the same time then it
is really funny he says to Tom Price
Health and Human Services Secretary part
of a bunch of children because people
who are aged 12 to 18 they're Tom Price
doesn't get to vote on Trump care then
he'll fire him which is it's just great
to threaten to fire everyone in your
cabinet the same way good good process
here by the way you're going to get the
votes hey you better get them they
better get it oh you bet otherwise
they'll say Tom you're fired I'll get
somebody okay he threatens to fire him
and then he threatens Jeff Sessions so
this is really kind of garbage this is
you know a garbage way to act so is a
bunch of children remember and President
Trump who shows up and Jeff Sessions is
an Eagle Scout by the way right he not
invited to this right all the other girl
scouts are there not Jeff Sessions and
he implies that Jeff Sessions is
disloyal to him okay so he's reading the
Boy Scout Oath okay the Boy Scout Oath
is sort of the opposite of trumps
personal creative duty and so he starts
reading it and he just breaks it in the
middle to make a snide reference about
Jeff Sessions unbelievable great Boy
Scouts become great great Americans as
the Scout law says a scout is
trustworthy loyal we could use some more
loyalty I won't tell you that okay and
then the rest of the crowd continues on
with the oath because they all know the
oh I love that he's ripping Jeff
Sessions in the middle of that and it's
pretty amazing so well well done just
well done by the way breaking news from
The Wall Street Journal Trump is now
saying to The Wall Street Journal
accessions who's the only senator to
endorse from the primaries did so
because of big crowds not loyalty which
is insane okay I know senator sessions
that's absolute garbage and here is
Trump ripping him in front of a bunch of
children the best moment of this was
where Trump who legitimately at this
point is starting like in front a bunch
of kids pirated this would sound like my
daughter and grandfather you know drunk
around
campfire starting to tell a story about
the old days here is Donald Trump
telling children remembered their kids a
story about life and developers in New
York City what in the world and he said
yes I would he so badly wanted to get
bored with this life of yachts and
sailing and all of the things he did in
the South of France and other places you
won't get bored right you know
truthfully your workers you'll get bored
too believe me of course having a few
good years like that isn't so bad but
what happened is he bought back his
company and he bought back a lot of
empty land and he worked hard and
getting it zoning and he worked hard and
starting to develop and in the end he
failed that he failed badly lost all of
his money he went personally bankrupt
and he was now much older and I saw him
at a cocktail party and it was very sad
because the hottest people in New York
were at this party was the party of
Steve Ross Steve Ross who was one of the
great people he came up and discovered
really founded Time Warner and he was a
great guy had a lot of successful people
that the party what is he talking and I
was doing well so I got invited to the
party I was very young what in the world
and all the kids are like um grandpa
your hearing aid what what my favorite
part of the speech is where he said that
we beat Hillary Clinton thanks to people
getting out and voting like you most of
the people that are under 18 so if we're
going to investigate voter fraud and all
the Boy Scouts are voting that's problem
okay so the media is going nuts over
this of course the media goes nuts over
everything they've decided that this is
the worst thing that has ever happened
in the history of American politics
again I'm not willing to hear that from
the same media that's been ripping the
Boy Scouts up and down and trying to
destroy them is it appropriate for firm
to do this of course not are we used to
Trump doing inappropriate things yes
this is the least of my concerns it's
also semi charming and ridiculous but
the President of the United States is
getting up there like my grandpa on
depends you know getting up there and
telling stories irrelevant stories about
his days in the schemata business like
what in the
world so with all this craziness going
unfortunately we have a second party
that's intelligent and with it and
really cares about you no no we don't
actually turns out that's the Democratic
Party says been in giant fail so I love
this the Democrats are still trying to
figure out what their messages well they
have no clue but their messages so Chuck
Schumer he came out yesterday and he
said you know it seems that people don't
get our message this is the Senate
Minority Leader people don't get I think
the problem is people may get your
message actually here's Schumer on the
message week after week month after
month we're going to roll out specific
pieces here that are quite different
than the Democratic Party you heard in
the past we were too cautious we were
too namby-pamby this is sharp bold and
will appeal them to both the old Obama
coalition let's say the young lady who's
just getting out of college and the
Democratic voters who deserted us for
Trump the blue collar workers I'm a
whiter dynamics George is our strength
someday we are going to go Matt it okay
again just amazing like they think
they've really got it in control this
time we're going to this time we're
really going to push our message but
here's the problem there's an inherent
contradiction in the Democratic message
as we have talked about they're two
separate wings of the Democratic Party
fighting for sentence right now wing
number one the intersectional wing right
the idea that the Barack Obama wing of
the party we're going to cobble together
all of these various identity groups and
they will come together and then once
they have come together they will form
majority and they will push legislation
right is Obama's theory but we have to
first separate them out in the groups
and then pander to each group as
necessary and call white people racists
in order to provide a common point of
opposition that's group number one group
number two is the Bernie Sanders
socialist okay we're not so into the
intersectionality we just like big
government we need big government
solutions socialism works for everyone
socialism wipes out all of the
distinctions between colors and
ethnicities and religions just more
socialism for everybody these are an
open conflict Schumer says we don't need
to choose we can do both
not so much it's a false choice there
doesn't have to be a division in fact
there must not be a division the vision
we're laying out unites both coalition's
and unifies the Democratic Party it will
have a larger stronger appeal to
Americans of all economic levels and all
political stripes it will appeal to the
young women who just graduated from
college in Los Angeles the factory
worker in Akron who's now only making
$11 an hour and the single mom in
Buffalo cleaning toilets on minimum wage
okay so this is you know actually it's
going to be very difficult for you to
bridge that gap considering the one half
of your party hates the other half of
your party you're gonna lose the
blue-collar voters so long as you insist
on making white males the object of all
of your ire in order to unify the rest
of your multicultural base so
fortunately we have two parties that are
in full disarray not just one again it
looks like the Republicans may be able
to pass something through the Senate
let's see what it is I'm optimistic that
maybe it'll make some good changes and I
would give you my evaluation of a bill
once we've seen it because this process
has been hot garbage thus far you know
the attempts you spin out a bill without
anyone having seen it because to mystery
I'm not a fan of this I'm kind of
transparency I'm old enough to remember
when the Republicans ran on the promise
that any piece of legislation be up for
three full days so people could read it
before there is any sort of vote on it
now we put that by the wayside because
hopefully if people just don't know
what's in any bill we can ram it through
really best we'll find out what's in it
tomorrow hopefully and I will have some
sort of synopsis for you on that okay
before I get the things I like things I
hate in some deconstruction of the
culture I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at my Patriot supplies
so right now if you are concerned about
the possibility of some sort of natural
disasters and some even a brownout you
know some situation where you can't get
to the grocery store and there's and
there's problem getting access to food
then you really need to talk to my
friends over my Patriot supply that's
why I depend on them to help prepare me
and my crew for survival with their
incredible survival food they have a
survival food supply for just $99 which
includes one hundred and two servings of
breakfasts lunches and dinners for less
than a dollar per serving people at the
office of try that they say that it
tastes like home cooking
number is eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or prepare or
prepare with been calm prepare with been
calm only $99 plus free shipping eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or check it out at prepare with
been calm again it's ninety nine bucks
to make sure that your family is safe
it's like a family four that means the
year they're going to be safe for you
know you know thirty meals parade for
each was you should be safe for a while
and and that can take you through some
dangerous times if God forbid something
happens between you two go to my patreon
supply and check them out prepare with
been calm okay so time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like so at the end of
Dunkirk one of the great choices one of
the great directorial choices the
Christopher Nolan the director makes is
that he doesn't use the music of Hans
Zimmer at the very end who's kind of
normal composer instead he uses some
music by Edward Elgar Edward Elgar is a
very famous British composer he's most
famous for writing pomp and circumstance
so everybody knows music he's been real
graduation that's Edward Elgar very
famous music so I wanted to do the today
some music that's used in movies that is
not actually moving music it's actually
just classical music used in other
movies so this is most famous for being
used venues and bunch of movies but it's
most famous for being used in platoon in
the scene where Willem Dafoe's character
is being shot you hear this come over
the you hear this come over the
soundtrack it's Samuel Barber's Adagio
for Strings one of the more beautiful
pieces ever composed and here's what it
sounds like
[Music]
you
this piece is composed in 1936 by again
Samuel Barber it was played on the
announcement over radio that FDR was
dead it was played and they when when it
was announced that JFK was dead on
television it was played it appeared in
just a ton of movies the Elephant Man
platoon lorenzo le i thought it was from
Lorenzo's oil it's been played to comic
effect even inside the Pope actually in
episode Simpsons in South Park it's been
played so often now that people actually
use it as a joke right but it's um it's
a great piece very effective and very
affecting and Samuel Barber is one of
the great modern American composers that
1981 I mean 1910 to 1981 and he has a
lot of terrific music that's what's in
it too okay other things that I like so
everybody is focused in on Kid Rock
running for Senate in Michigan that's of
course because Kid Rock is super famous
he sold 14 million records he is
extraordinarily popular he's done this
routine where he makes sure that all the
tickets that are sold for his concerts
have to be twenty dollars or less so
he's a populist but there's somebody
who's better qualified running for that
same Senate seat is name is John James
and here is an ad for John James running
for office in Michigan I'm a Republican
because I'm conservative
specifically the exceptionalism of our
country and our Constitution and they
must be defended I'm pro-gun I
understand that James Madison wrote this
document and listed the number two thing
behind religion speech and the right to
assemble the right to keep in their arms
it's that important I believe that life
begins at conception it's a god-given
miracle Michigan deserves a leader who's
lived in the real world who understands
national security who understands how to
provide economic opportunity because
they've actually created jobs Michigan
deserves a leader to make sure that
everyone has a fair shot you do that by
understanding economic opportunity and
by understanding national security
because you don't do both in our future
will not be as bright as it can be I'm
John James and I'm exploring along the
USS
okay so this guy would be a rock star in
a Republican Party in the pre celebrity
here this guy is a former military guys
US Marine he's 36 years old he is black
he is the CEO of Renaissance global
logistics which is a logistics and
warehousing firm based in Detroit he is
basically the perfect candidate right I
mean he's articulate and and as Joe
Biden might say brighten articulate but
obviously he's a smart guy with terrific
record and and just a great cam and
we're doing the interview with him over
at Daily wire to check it out we need
more candidates like that we need more
Congress people like that I understand
the thrill of celebrity and I understand
why everybody is interested in celebrity
but I mean come on folks at some point
we're going to need to actually nominate
people who have a deeply conservative
streak who know what policies they care
about and who have a history of running
businesses and dealing with communities
and celebrity politics is not my bag and
I'm getting kind of tired of it okay
other things okay so let's do some one
quick thing I hate and then we'll get
deconstructing the culture so the thing
I hate this week is that every everyday
on Huffington Post there is some insane
thing where somebody does something
crazy or insane and then Huffington Post
says this person is crushing a
stereotype by doing a crazy thing so
here's what it is this time
okay barcelona-based since that birth
control uses paint and whitter to
highlight parts and functions of the
body
women have been conditioned to feel
ashamed of like stretch marks and
menstruation so now if you have stretch
mark she's painting it she's a vibrant
rainbow of colors to highlight stretch
marks on the skin and to show the beauty
of menstruation on underwear sanitary
pads and tampons
she's hope PopSugar it started with her
own journey toward self-love any time
anyone has to tell you about their
journey toward self-love they're a jerk
okay like I don't want to hear about
your journey toward self-love it's your
business not mine not interested just
she it says I've not always felt
comfortable with my period and stretch
marks she said TMI gang well when did
this phrase TMI go out of style that
sort of like at this TMI phrase the
overall I've not always felt secure with
my body over the years and after
internal reflection I saw that if I did
not accept anything about my body hair
stretch marks I could never love or
accept me really why
why pet you love or accept you with your
flaws or do you have to why can't you
love like certain things about your body
but not other things like if we all love
being overweight we'd all stay
overweight another thing you should like
cultivate a hatred for your own body god
forbid but I don't know why you taking
pictures of like the parts of yourself
that nobody really wants to see is is is
a beneficial thing why that is a
worthwhile thing to do
she says she paints underwear and she
paints stretch marks and it says you'll
never look at your body the same way
again and say so then there's a picture
of a sanitary pad with glitter on it it
is so beautiful mmm-hmm that's also what
happens when my three year old daughter
gets hold of the sanitary pads and takes
it into dates and takes it into her
craft room so I'm not sure why this
qualifies you to be some sort of
artistic genius but everything must be
cheered now up to and including bodily
functions I'm looking forward to the
male response which is painting your
poop and that'll be that'll be really
fun painting your bowel movements
painting your beer-bellied
I have never felt comfortable with my
beer belly but now I've painted in all
the colors of the rainbow and given it a
frog map okay okay times deconstruct a
little bit of culture we need to leave
that behind and move on with our lives
and deconstruct the culture so one of
the things that's been bugging me this
week is that all of these actors are now
suggesting that it is very very very
very important that movies that are
aimed at children and entertainment
pieces contain all sorts of political
messaging so yesterday the lead voice
actor for the emoji movie insisted that
the movie is a very very important way
of fighting president Trump's
administration rather than just a film
about talking faces the coiny Alex
Griswold over at the free beacon we
started with the Huffington Post we
trashed his co-workers on Silicon Valley
which is a show that I think is
hilarious said right before the election
asked how much money did you donate you
Hollywood elite how much did you donate
to Hillary Clinton's campaign and
everybody in the cast had nothing they
hadn't given a dollar maybe because
she's the worst candidate in American
history Miller said however he's very
much on board emoji movie said how rare
is it we get an opportunity to do an
original property right there's an
opportunity to do something optimistic
positivistic and you know we have very
few weapons in the current
administration one of them is target
younger demographic and try and help
them understand and adopt progressive
values the movie has a lot to say to
women how they have limitless potential
and whatever character literally breaks
through a glass ceiling hmm this is a
movie able to take my daughter to see I
don't want to see your political
messaging TJ Miller I'm not interested
in what Hollywood thinks my child ought
to say I'm interested in what I think my
child ought to see she's my child you
don't know her you don't care about her
I do it's my job to determine what my
child should see a new messaging in the
emoji movie is not going to forward the
ball at all in American politics you
want to know what made Trump this is one
of the things that made Trump is the
incessant attempts by the left to infuse
every single damn thing with politics
everything everything has to has to be
infused of politics opportun including a
stupid movie with poop emojis played by
Patrick Stewart
you wonder why Hollywood is going to the
going to the dogs this is one of the
reasons you want to know why people are
seeing superhero movies right now
because they don't want to be hit with
your stupid messaging Your Honor I don't
hurt did great business besides being a
very good movie it's because there is no
political messaging and Dunkirk and no
matter how hard your left try they
couldn't find felicity political
messaging and Dunkirk and so people were
willing to see it so let's see
spider-man or we'll go see Marvel movies
or we'll go to DC movies we'll go see
all of these superhero movies because
we're not expecting to be sucker punch
but we know that if we go see a serious
drama there's at least a 35% chance
there's going to be some back end and
slap at Trump or conservatives or
Republicans in their I was watching a
movie last night I'm playing him in New
York I was watching this movie that was
what was the name of this film it was
that is huge casters Amy Adams and
Michael Shannon and for some reason as I
get older I forget the names and movies
in any case this this it was nocturnal
animal that's name of the film so
nocturnal animals is the film that opens
with probably the worst opening I've
ever seen to a pretty good movie the
rest of the movie is fine but halfway
through the movie there's a scene where
the main character played by Amy Adams
just starts ripping on her mother and
she says she's a terrible person because
she's a racist sexist bigoted homophobe
and of course she's a Republican of
course she's a Republican and it's just
like okay do we need that sucker punch
right here in the middle like was that
necessary now it turns out that it's not
as much of a sucker punch as it seems
but that sort of thing is what people
attempt to avoid when they go to the
movies if how they wants to continue
poisoning the popular
culture to the point where we can't even
share movies and entertainment with each
other then the end result is going to be
a more polarized culture not a less
polarized culture
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow to
talk about John McCain's apparently big
speech that I'm just messin on Twitter
will talk also about what exactly Trump
care is going to be plus the latest on
the Jeff Sessions saga when we return
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]